>>Well, India I think is sitting at a very
exciting stage of economic
development because I believe this is the
time that the rebalancing of
economic power in the world is taking place.
It is countries like India and other Asian
countries that are growing
at a much faster rate compared to the Western
countries.
What is driving India's growth is the very
strong domestic consumption
and to that we will add a huge force of investment
in infrastructure
that is likely to take place going forward.
So growth drivers of domestic consumption
and of investment.
I think we are poise to see very, very high
rates of growth for the
country which means that clearly, a rebalancing
of economic power will
take place.
And therefore, I think at this stage of the
world economic allotments,
so to say, India is sitting at a very exciting
state.
India is not only going to become a very strong
superpower but India in
a way is going to drive the world's economic
growth in the next decade.